évidemment que tous les maires que nous
sommes souhaitant la reprise de la vie
du pays qu'on veut bien sûr soutenir les
familles qu'on pour qu'il puisse aller
travailler il faut bien entendu proposer
un du scolaire pour autant on a un
protocole qui tombe mercredi ou jeudi
dernier on a une semaine et me fait
trois semaines que ça a été annoncé
ce protocole honnêtement les faits sans
aucune application correcte du terrain
aucune prise en charge financière de ce
que représente ce surcoût et puis
surtout une absence de protection pénale
pour l'humeur
l'état fournit des masques aux
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
nous on fait quoi avec nos animateurs
nous aide c'est m
donc on n'en fournit aussi donc ça aussi
c'est un surcoût aujourd'hui les masques
on sait tous en dehors du fait que c'est
un surcoût c'est aussi une denrée rare
évidemment qu'on mettra en route la
cantine après quel format je ne sais pas
on a tout entendu ces quatre derniers
jours on se fait manger les enfants de
place ont laissé manger dans le contexte
war on paie des paniers repas
je suis en concertation avec à la fois
les parents d'élèves et avait à la fois
les enseignants comment on tient un
enfant de 8 ans dans une classe toute la
journée et avec la pause déjeuner deux
dentiers juste pas possible